Well, I'm not convinced that the work is as urgent as this report suggests,...
...so perhaps we should...
Oh come on, the building is practically falling down!
Sorry Lin, I don't think Tan had finished.
We'll get to you in a minute.
Sorry.
As I was saying, perhaps we should get a second opinion before we spend any money.
Thank you, Tan.
What's your opinion, Walter?
Well, as far as I'm concerned, it's a question of safety, so I think we should go ahead.
Are you suggesting that someone could get hurt?
In my opinion, yes.
If you ask me, there is a serious risk of an accident.
And it's not a recent problem.
Are you implying we should have done something earlier?
Much earlier. It's a real concern.
Hear, hear!
In that case, I agree. We should do something now.
I think so, too.
Thank you, Walter.
Well, if there's no...
Excuse me, Madam Chairperson.
Yes, Barbara.
What about the problem with parking? There were no places again this morning.
Maybe if you got to work on time...
All comments through the chair if you don't mind, Walter.
Parking isn't on the agenda for this meeting.
Perhaps you could suggest it for our next meeting, Barbara.
Well, if there's no more discussion, we'll put it to a vote.
Hear, hear!